إنها عبارة موسيقية حول كل ما هو
خطأ في لبنان لا ماء ولا طعام ولا
إنترنت ولا عمل ولا وقود ولا أمان ولا
مال ،
يلخص مقطع الفيديو هذا الذي وضعه النشطاء الشكوك العميقة التي
يشعر بها الكثيرون في الوقت الذي يمر فيه البلد الذي يمر بأزمة عميقة
في الانتخابات البرلمانية
و  لا أحد أكثر تشككًا
من سكان المدينة الفقيرة
[الموسيقى]
يقول سمير إنه يفضل بيع الليمون الخاص به بدلاً
من إضاعة الوقت في التصويت لأي
عدد كبير من المرشحين ،
لا أحد منهم يفيدني
بمجرد انتهاء الانتخابات.  سوف تأتي
بالسكاكين وتبدأ في ذبح
الجميع
قليلاً من المبالغة ربما ولكن
الشعور واضح
في أكتوبر 2019 عشرات الآلاف من
الناس محشورين في ساحة الشهداء هذه
في قلب بيروت مطالبين بالتغيير
ولكن منذ ذلك الحين في لبنان
كان التغيير الوحيد للأسوأ
لفترة وجيزة كان هناك أمل قبل ثلاث سنوات
الغضب من الفساد وسوء الإدارة
أشعل الآمال في نهاية المطاف
النظام الطائفي المتهالك الذي أقيم بعد الحرب الأهلية
تم استبداله بشيء
يعكس إرادة الناس ،
ثم جاء فيروس
كورونا ، حيث دخل الاقتصاد الأجنبي بالفعل في السقوط الحر ،
ويعيش أربعة من كل خمسة لبنانيين الآن في
فقر ، وفقدت العملة 90 في المائة
من قيمتها
، وهذا
الانفجار في ميناء بيروت في آب / أغسطس 2020 أسفر عن مقتل
أكثر من 200 شخص.  جرح الآلاف
حتى الآن الطبقة السياسية التي أشرفت على
هذه الكوارث المعلقة على
جماعة حزب الله الشيعية المتشددة
نظمت تجمعات انتخابية حاشدة في محاولة
لإظهار أنها لا تزال تتمتع بدعم واسع على
أمل الحفاظ على ائتلافها
الذي يحتفظ بأغلبية برلمانية
وآخرون بقيادة رئيس الوزراء السابق سعد
العلي.  يقاطع الحريري زعيم الطائفة السنية
التصويت ، يزعم خُمس المرشحين أنهم
يمثلون أصواتًا من أجل التغيير ، لكنهم
منقسمون وغير منظمين ويعانون من نقص التمويل
المحلل لينز
يتساءل عما إذا كان الإصلاحيون القلائل الذين قد
يفوزون بمقاعد في البرلمان يمكنهم إجبار
النخبة السياسية على الاستماع
القوة هي لهجة الصم
وصناع التغيير
يلتقطون نبض  الناس ،
لكن أولئك القلائل الذين ينتهي بهم الأمر في
مقاعد السلطة التشريعية ،
سيكونون قادرين على ممارسة
التغيير للعديد من الأشخاص ، لكن كل هذا يعد مسرحًا
للعبث الشهر الماضي أمير دونداس وعائلته على
متن قارب على أمل الوصول إلى قبرص التي
غرق فيها.  لقد غرق أطفاله الثلاثة أكثر
من 30 شخصًا ما زالوا في عداد المفقودين ،
أردت أن أعيش ، أخبرني أن أرى
أطفالي يكبرون ، قال ابني أريد
أن أصبح طيارًا ، أرادت ابنتي أن تصبح
معلمة ، أحلامك هي
لأطفالك ، لقد قتلوا أحلامي.
وسط يقول إنه لن يصوت
بن ويدمان سي إن طرابلس